[Music]
while some of us were learning about our
ABCs others were solving complex algebra
problems and composing their first
symphonies from child painters to math
whizzes these kids will definitely blow
your mind wait until you hear about a
two-year-old with an IQ as high as
Albert Einstein's don't forget to
subscribe to the things and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's check
out the Tim kids that are true G mrs.
Carson and Canon Kim we're putting these
two together because they're brothers
having one child genius is amazing but
what happens when you have two Carson
and Cannon were just 11 and 14 years old
when they graduated high school and
college
Carson graduated from the Texas
Christian University and guided degree
in physics with minors in Chinese and
math he wants to get a PhD but his
brother Canon wants to be an astronaut
Canon graduated high school and started
attending TCU and 2017 to study
astrophysics and engineering it's
amazing to believe these kids are
actually just 11 and 14 imagine going to
college at the age of 12 and already
knowing exactly what you want to do with
your life not only that but you're
already working hard for it these two
kids are true child geniuses Carson
started attending TCU at the age of 10
and became the youngest graduate ever
these kids are unbelievably talented and
it all started with their mom who
converted one of their spare rooms at
home into a classroom little did she
know that these kids will grow out of
their ABCs pretty soon and go through
the entire curriculum in just an hour
after ramen Hussein in January 2018
Abdi ramen was crowned as the smartest
child in the world the 13 year old Abdul
Rahman comes from Egypt that he competed
at the intelligent mental arithmetic
international competition and won first
place this child is a total genius at
just 13 years old
Abdul Rahman was able to solve 230
complex arithmetic problems in just
eight minutes and here we are thinking
about how we weren't able to finish our
math homework back in the day and we
probably still can't this competition
hosted kids from over 70 countries the
kids were put to the test in a series of
tasks to see which of them will take the
crown of the smartest kid in the world
and out of all the kids Abdul Rahman won
he says that his achievement as a result
of the support and guidance he received
from his teachers and family which just
proves that talent and intelligence
needs to be nurtured his teacher
explains that Abdul Rahman has been
training his mental capabilities for
five years before the competition yep
that's how serious he was about this so
how does one become the smartest kid in
the world the intelligence Education
Group encourages people to help develop
their kids mental faculty at an early
age Adam the pilots if you follow the
viral internet trends you've probably
heard of this kid before the 5 year old
Adam Mohammed Amer impressed everyone by
his extensive knowledge on how to fly a
plane you probably saw the adorably
impressive video of Adam joining the
pilots in the cockpit and basically
running the show when it comes to
telling them about the functionalities
of every button the kid could seriously
fly a plane if he got a chance the viral
video shows Adam explaining the complex
machinery and controls without even
stuttering as the video went on Adam
became even more specific and his
knowledge and press millions of viewers
when he was asked what he wants to be
when he grows up he of course says that
he'll be a captain and with that
extensive knowledge we're pretty sure
that will be possible
Etihad Airways actually invited Adams
who attend the company training academy
for a day of flight test seriously this
kid knows his stuff and his future seems
pretty much secured so if you have a
question about what to do in case of
airplane emergencies we're pretty sure
Adam will have all the answers a true
genius Lidia sebastian jeana's kids can
be found everywhere and their age has no
boundaries the twelve-year-old Lydia
Sebastian shocked everyone when she took
a Mensa IQ test at a London College and
achieved a maximum score some kids have
totally different aspirations than most
Itzik Lydia a whole year of begging her
parents to let her do the exam and she
was eventually able to do it during her
school holidays the maximum result you
can achieve on a Mensa IQ test is 162
and Lydia humbly said that she just gave
it her best shots how inspiring is that
the Mensa IQ test consists of two
sections the first one consists of 150
questions assessed through passages of
complex tests the second section is much
more advanced
complex as it includes 50 diagram ik
questions this allows people whose
English isn't their first language to
take the test and achieve the same score
ask some of their native English
counterparts
Lydia is now in the top 1% of people
with a maximum score Mensa invites
everyone that scores a top 2% on the
test to join the society it also looks
like Lydia is just naturally talented as
she's been playing the violin since the
age of 4 and she started talking when
she was just 6 months old
autumn de forests you don't need to be a
math whiz to be considered a child
genius or a prodigy and autumn DeForest
is the ultimate proof of that statement
of course anyone with an iconic name
like this will probably have a pretty
awesome future right at 14 years autumn
became a creative genius her talent was
first discovered when she was just five
years old after she asked her dad if she
could help paint wood in the garage he
gave her a piece of plywood and by the
time he turned around autumn already
completed an image that resembled the
work of the famous painter Mark Rothko
since then Adam has been painting plenty
of cool photos which are now hanging all
around the house this creative genius
also used her talent to grow a
successful business her photos have
grossed at about 7 million dollars in
sales adam's exceptional artwork is also
frequently featured in various galleries
and art shows seriously we can't even
draw a decent stick figure and this kid
is out there painting some of the
coolest pieces we have ever seen Vivian
Shan if you're struggling getting
through university he'll be really
jealous and a 13 year old Vivian Vivian
has been crowned as a genius at the age
of seven when she already knew how to
add subtract and multiply negative
numbers and decimals she also learned to
read and write Mandarin at the age of
two she quickly advanced through her
education as she didn't feel challenged
enough in class and if that's not
impressive enough
Vivian wrapped up per year at Prince
Edward Island University in 2018 she
seems to be pretty much soaring through
her biology degree and she's expected to
finish it before she can get a driver's
license she finished her first semester
with grades all above 91% which is just
unbelievable imagine sitting in a class
with a 13 year old who's probably
smarter than you but even though this 13
year old is in class with people aged up
to 22 years she's
she's still able to make friends she
said she's able to connect with them
because they don't really part much
seriously were officially jealous now
Alma Deutscher but let's go back to some
of the more creative child geniuses Alma
was born in 2005 and at the age of 10
she was first crowned a child prodigy of
the music world Alma is known as an
amazing performer but she's also an
incredible composer it's hard to believe
that she was already composing music at
the age of 10 while some of her peers
just started learning an instrument
almost talent was first discovered on
YouTube when her video was shared by
Stephen Fry who called her a new Mozart
although it's essential that successful
musicians develop their musical talents
at a young age musical talent prodigies
still attract an audience that just
can't believe what they're hearing
of course Alma acknowledges that she's
very different compared to Mozart and
while her parents question whether the
comparison to Mozart will set high
expectations for this prodigy to write a
masterpiece by a certain age we're still
very much sure that all this feature
will be incredibly bright and full of
music but she's not only talented when
it comes to music this kid has a natural
stage presence that can easily enchants
a crowds seriously we can't wait to see
what the future holds for this one Joey
Alexander a grammy-nominated piano
prodigy you bets we're telling you these
kids are something else
Joey is a jazz pianist who was just 13
years old when he played for President
Obama at the White House he's already
making music with albums also featuring
his own original compositions his
creative genius earned him a title of
being one of the youngest Grammy
nominees that's right he was actually
nominated for a Grammy at just their
team you usually hear that from young
actors but not from someone who plays
dad's time also named him as one of the
top next generation leaders and praised
Joey for his incredible talents talk
about having an accomplished life at the
age of 13 when he was just 9 years old
he won the inaugural master Jam Jazz
Festival and at the age of 10 his
YouTube videos were discovered by nine
time Grammy winner
Wynton Marsalis who invited him to come
play with him
Joey truly has an amazing gift and it
seems like he's in all of his own
musical abilities but despite being a
musical
this kid still is very much down to
earth and doesn't really care about
having more than 100,000 fans on
Facebook all he cares about is making
music
Dylan Tom seriously kids that are math
geniuses are on a whole new level
while we struggled getting through our
schools math curriculum the 12 year old
Dylan was totally bored by it in the
true Mathilde style Dylan frequently
visited local libraries to find more of
a challenging material on anything
algebra related the Singaporean Ministry
of Education noticed his impressive
algebra knowledge and he was soon paired
up with a secondary school teacher who
introduced him to the advanced math
curriculum regular 12 year olds couldn't
handle at that age since then he had
mentors from universities that helped
him study abstract linear algebra his
knowledge was so impressive
his mentor stated that Dylan would
easily get a place at any of the
top-tier American universities so if
someone tells you that math isn't fun
and no one really enjoys it make sure to
mention this child genius still and make
sure he continues to get intellectually
challenged by participating in robotics
other mathematics and even table tennis
competitions in Singapore since then
he's been part of several international
science and mathematics competitions and
helped win his high school of pretty
often first-place trophy in
international mathematical Olympiad we
wonder if he could compete against our
next kid Elise tin Roberts at the age of
two most kids entered the terrible two
stage which means a lot of tantrums for
them and a lot of lost nerves for their
caretakers but at least in Roberts was
crowned as the world's smartest kid the
news broke out back in 2009 and you can
see this adorable little girl's face
just about everywhere she was just five
months old when she spoke her first
words she was eight when she started
walking and at ten months she was
already running around she learned how
to read her own name before her first
birthday and soon she was able to count
to ten in English as well as Spanish her
parents were wondering if it's all just
a coincidence
so they took Elise to a specialist
education psychologist where at least
completed a 45-minute test we couldn't
even focus when we were two years old
yell alone finish a tests but for at
least it paid off because she became the
youngest member to join the Mensa IQ
Society that's right I just the age of
two for
Q was measured at 156 points in case
you're wondering Albert Einstein's IQ
was measured at 160 since then she is
known as the smartest kid around and
that's all for our video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]